you ready yeah let's do it
oh hey guys what's up
not done
so what do you think of our prequel the
DC's Avengers part what we accomplished
what bottle did in several boobies with
just what movie with the exact same
results sorry brother we saw a good
Batman Superman movie what I thought you
liked it no kinda well Betty did like it
no kinda well then what's the problem
people have been waiting years to see
this team-up
yeah and the choices you made were just
so it's so DC this is arguably the most
anticipated comic-book movie of all time
and that people have been waiting to see
it even before it was announced there
have been several comics where Batman
and Superman are together as well as
cartoons but despite there being tons of
Batman and Superman movies there had
never been one with them together
however with the marvel crossovers
proving to be exceptionally successful
DC felt it was time to throw their head
into the ring and use this as a means to
start their own DC Cinematic Universe
despite a very strong opening its box
office dropped a shocking 68 percent the
following weekend how bad is that Batman
and Robin second weekend had a 63
percent drop Wow that means more people
went back to see that film rather than
Batman vs Superman what the hell have
you done
Zack alright well why don't you just
start from the beginning of the film
alright wait wait you're just playing a
few minutes for Batman Begins exactly
after showing a flashback we've seen
done so much I'm surprised there's not
action figures of it we cut to yet
another flashback of Bruce driving
through metropolis while was being
destroyed by some big business associate
you have to get out of Metropolis why oh
wow good thing you called me I never
would have looked out the window to
notice
I will avenge you man the audience
barely knows as well as all the lives
were only now acknowledging my feet
Superman's fault flash forward a year
later as thank God
Louis figures out Clark Kent is Superman
and they discuss their future together
Clark I'm concerned people were shot to
death in the desert and they're blaming
you for some reason hey Zack what's that
about yeah what's that about well if you
can't see how they would mistake
Superman shooting people to death yeah
what they think he is Batman I don't
think I should have to explain the
obvious besides this leads to a very
deep conversation I just don't know if
the world is ready to accept you or if
what you're doing is right or if it is
right if it's just gonna make things
worse you're standing in the bathtub I'm
standing in the bathtub I feel like we
were discussing some very important
issues here but I'm standing in the
bathtub good point but it looks like one
of the people intimidated by Supes is
Lex Luthor play remarkably without an
apology by Jesse Eisenberg hey mister
centered man look what I got a shiny
green rock that can weaken Kryptonians
I'll let you have it if you give me
access to Zod ship you seem completely
unbalanced why would I give you access
to any of that because I've got Jolly
Ranchers sold yep cherry cherry by the
way Wonder Woman's in this movie hello
okay so what's the prep butt
first jesse eisenberg second if superman
took down military satellites trying to
track him why the hell didn't he take
Zod ship a weapon from Krypton away from
them
third jesse eisenberg four there's no
reason for Luthor to hate Superman here
in the comics and movies Superman foils
his evil plans constantly so it makes
sense to try to kill him
but in this movie if anything Lex Luthor
benefits from Superman as he said he has
contracts to rebuild everything that was
destroyed his motivations are completely
backward well like everyone else he's
afraid of Superman's massive power and
ability to destroy me stay later that's
like five Superman with a fist for our
brave and what was that other thing oh
yeah Jesse Eisenberg whether you want to
call him Lex Luthor jr. or whatever this
is a beyond awkward performance even at
his corneas Lex is a powerful charming
diabolical mastermind
he always had a cool attitude a business
type mindset and a suave calculating
demeanor this guy is more like Roger
Rabbit if he was a supervillain but at
least he introduces Clark Kent to Bruce
Wayne I don't really get them hating
each other yeah but why we have a vague
understanding of why Batman hates
Superman but there's really no reason
Superman should hate Batman so nice to
meet you Bruce Wayne the pleasure's all
mine Clark Kent
I hear Batman is trampling on civil
liberties making people live in fear
thinking he's above the law
I hear Superman is powerfully danger is
there putting tons of people in harm's
way and there's even a 1% chance that
he's unstable the key must be destroyed
by the way when a woman's in this movie
hello howdy boys
god I love bringing people together this
reminds me of the time that I ended up
through the fifth week
that's Lex Luthor No right so does he
ever shut up I don't know let's ask him
ha well I guess I had that coming
see you later boys
this is like a bad dream man no that's
my department
what yeah I want most people to look at
me and say he was such a good Batman he
could do most of it in his sleep so I do
most of them I sleep in fact this is a
dream sequence right now Oh kidding yeah
future characters things you don't
understand yes one must be clever
hello master Wayne
what is it I just don't know
commissioner Alfred I just feel like the
motivations of the next film are being
figured out before the motivations of
this film
let's do not get me grandchildren time
soon not this again yes this again it
gets even weirder when Batman is chasing
down some guys who have the Kryptonite
and Superman stops him right in his
tracks for pretty much no reason well by
only weakness that can kill you
I hate you why because you're a
vigilante you're vigilante I hate you
because you're responsible for a ton of
death you're responsible for a ton of
death that's ridiculous I value human
life much more than you ever just stop
hypocritic or I'm a typic ridding go
back to Gotham it's literally across the
street tell me something do you believe
or cool or cool yeah that's what I
thought
listen detective if I'm so bloodthirsty
as you say I am why haven't I killed you
already
because I intimidate you boo you never
answered me do you bleed you will what
did you say nothing nothing Oh real
mature
you
okay so you guys don't think Batman is
super bad have enough reasons to hate
each other but hey you gotta give me
credit Lex Luthor his plans pretty basic
how by inviting Superman to the Capitol
building and then blowing it up causing
people to hate a mall but even in the
movie they know he didn't do it and why
would Superman use a bomb he doesn't
need one but it's okay because he scares
SuperBetter to exile
what was that Lexus plan I don't know oh
yes yes that's exactly one why does he
make another Kryptonian then he tricks
the incredibly advanced Kryptonian
technology using fake fingerprints and
forces it to genetically combine his DNA
with that absorb you know genetic
mutation is forbidden by Kryptonians but
they're all dead so it really doesn't
matter even though your fingerprints
convinced me otherwise I'll roll with it
boy don't you witch this is how all
advanced technology worked this phone is
password protected yeah but the guy who
owned to die oh okay here's all his info
she got pot oh hey whose phone is that
that's yours what Oh give it up whoo
look at all the Spartan porn I don't
need this I'm friends of Christopher
Nolan
so well in exile clerk comes across his
dead father building a snow fort this is
either because a he's a ghost be quarts
hallucinating see more inconsistent
Kryptonian technology or D if this is
really your biggest question through all
this
you're on quaaludes nut up okay
meanwhile Luthor's men sneaked up on
Lois and kidnapper
oh don't worry this happens all the time
I brought my own chloroform and she
wakes up on top of Lex's building a
little my dear I knew it
through my journalistic skills I figured
out it was you thus completing my
incredibly essential role to this film
oh you figured out that Lex Luthor was
the bad guy huh real brain scratcher
there nobody else would have figured
that one out
you really solidified yourself as a
necessity there you know what I was
doing while you were figuring out that
incredible info figured out who's
Superman wasn't figured out who Batman
was and I plan to kidnappings to take
place on the night that he was planning
to finish him off see see there you go
and you know what the best part is I did
all of that off-screen so even I don't
know how I did all this impossible shit
um whew is it chilly up here where's
that just the cold uselessness of your
character hey I'm really important oh
yeah sure
let's get to the one thing do we know
you're good at it's over Luthor your
mama says black says Blair no but she
will when I slit her throat now go kill
Batman because I think it'd be cool okay
this is it we barely have a reason to
hate each other except we hate the fact
that the other one kills I'll kill you
for that
yeah and pretty high drama huh
or isn't this it isn't this what you've
always wanted to see yeah it's what
we've always wanted to see but not why
we wanted to see it we want to see
Batman and Superman fight because they
have different ideologies that we enjoy
one is dark and aggressive the other is
kind and hopeful seeing two points of
view that are different but we identify
with go ahead and head is deep and
conflicting drama but Superman is
fighting to save his mom and Batman is
fighting because he pretty much does
what he does it's not an epic fight if
the motivations are weak it is the
literal definition of forced yeah but
isn't it so cool the way Batman swigs of
a rat like a yo-yo yeah it is it it cool
the way super bad punches him across a
building yeah and wasn't it cool when
Batman sprayed it with kryptonite gas or
just minutes later he could stab him
with a kryptonite spear wait a minute
when do you just stab him with the spear
first huh yeah this is a battle brains
as well as brawn why didn't Batman just
stab him as his first move I am well
look Aquaman's at the movie hmm answer
the question okay we did it so people
could see more than fighting I'm cool
and there's your problem
they see them fighting but they don't
experience them fighting anyone can just
watch two people fight hell you can just
take to strangers put them in Batman and
Superman costumes and have them do cool
stuff but if you're constantly
questioning why throughout the whole
thing you're not experiencing it you're
constantly being distracted by elements
that don't add up
but perhaps you didn't hear me Aquaman's
a little league cyborg
no Zach no and man has the upper hand
until an amazing discovery is made
Bava
would you say I need to save mom oh my
god my mother's still alive no you idiot
your mothers have the same name this
instantly erases no hatred from now on
you and I will be best friends I'll
throw this over here then I've created
the ultimate Kryptonian devil I'll just
go and grab that what is this like the
fourth time I'll save you Lois and I'll
grab the sphere which is the only thing
that weakens me yeah it used to be like
that ha ha I've done it I've created the
ultimate Kryptonian devil candy Oh Oh my
face why'd you smear it all over my face
what's going on here Lex
I thought you hated Kryptonians now
you've made another one your plan makes
no sense
you don't get it my plan is chaos God
versus God anarchy the Bell has been run
dignity meaning let's put a smile on
that face Lex Luthor uh-huh you're
portraying Lex Luthor right now that's
nothing
what do you see how well we understand
doomsday doomsday yes we wrote him so
he's a combo of lexan Zod's DNA creating
I am your doomsday oh I will fuck him
but that's not what doomsday looks like
Oh what did you expect a monster evolved
from cloning thousands of alien babies
dying and being reborn until it created
the ultimate killing machine like in the
comic yeah well why would that look
anything like Zod and Luthor's got to
MDNA a combination of Zod and Luthor
should look exactly like that
Zod and Luthor where did this double
size double muscle brain dead dick
missing creature come from in fact wait
a minute
Lex Luthor combining his DNA with
Kryptonian DNA to create an
uncontrollable monster that's nuclear
man oh my god Zack Snyder is getting
inspiration from Superman Thor the worst
Superman movie ever but we got don't go
no way dude this isn't a contest for how
much shit you can jam in this movie we
loved these characters because they were
given time to develop just because you
give them the same name doesn't
automatically make them the same
character but what if we had the flash
shut the hell up okay
so after Wonder Woman finally joins the
team hello
oh I can stay this time awesome Batman
has a great idea we need to lure him
into the city towards the quick tonight
or all the innocent people are wouldn't
it be easier to bring the easily
transportable kryptonite here don't you
watch these movies we don't save people
from destruction we bring it to them
then Superman has a great idea I'm gonna
sacrifice myself to save us all are you
sure yes even though there's probably a
thousand other ways we can be doing this
right now but no I'm gonna sacrifice
myself no I meant are you sure you're
gonna kill him because wasn't killing
Zod a big deal in the first one yeah but
I got over it you seem to do that a lot
I wear fire ferrets Superman rushes to a
doomsday with the Kryptonite sphere
he dies Superman dies in the second
movie well don't forget there's even
more than that we use even more Jesus
symbolism don't worry we'll get through
all the Stations of the Cross Luthor
you're sent to jail see I have a bald
head now I'm totally Lex Luthor why so
serious and just when you think he's
really gone for girl a few specks of
dirt rise from his cuff until that maybe
just maybe
thus we've combined the most famous
Batman and Superman stories into one
emotional package giving you exactly
what you've always wanted to see come on
you know what I want to see no I want to
see the Justice League at his funeral
but now I can't I want to see a hero
slowly stripped of his life in the
ultimate battle instead of just being
stabbed in one swoop but now I can't I
want to build a connection with this
Superman the same way he built a
connection with me in hundreds of
stories but now I can't
I want to fear that this might be the
time that Superman doesn't make it back
but now I can't
how many comics were there before
Superman died hello hundreds thousands
and how many movies did you make with
him - - you killed him in two movies and
you barely even focused on him you know
what I want to see I want to see you
earn Superman's death this isn't fucking
Jimmy Olsen this is goddamn Superman he
deserves your time and respect
ditto this movie is trying to be Marvel
The Dark Knight Wonder Woman just as
leaked the death of Superman and Batman
vs Superman when Batman vs Superman
would have been more than enough the
reason we love so many of the stories
that you were trying to fit into this is
because each one was its own individual
story The Death of Superman wasn't also
a prequel to Suicide Squad or the
retelling of Dark Knight Returns it
focused on one story and allowed us to
get invested sure you have to compromise
a story when it comes to making a movie
but when you lose the heart and soul of
what made that story so special is it
worth just squeezing in instead of
devoting the time it deserves so I
that's what you really think huh well
I'm sorry that my movie didn't please
you in the least love it was pretty
awesome what as much as so many of those
scenes suck there's a lot of scenes that
are friggin amazing the action the
visuals Affleck as Batman irons as
Alfred when it did certain parts of the
comic right it was a pretty kick-ass
film so wait did you like it or not it's
not good I am glad that I saw it if
you're just looking for Batman and
Superman to fight each other you'll get
it it's just not in a story that makes
any sense
it's got a lot of cool scenes that are
hard to say not to go check it out so in
a strange way I'm still recommending it
I suppose that's all over the map but
then again your movies all over the map
so I guess it comes full circle if those
are your thoughts and why did you come
all the way out of here then well uh we
were thinking that maybe we could write
the next one
that is a very violent map
you
and I'm Batman
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this is one of the few
where I am actually not gonna show video
from their YouTube channel even though
there is video from in fact the imagery
is so graphic and so uncomfortable that
I was debating even whether or not to do
this charity but for that exact reason
that's why it really needs to be done
it's called kill the jigger dot-org and
a jigger is a sand flea the smallest
type of flea there is in tropical and
third-world countries where they can
burrow in through your foot and they can
just pretty much eat you from the inside
out and if you are brave enough to go
and see some of these videos and
everything it's it's tough it's really
rough but that is all the more reason
why these people need to exist and they
need to go and and kill these things I
mean these things survive by pretty much
burrowing into people's feet and just
like I said just destroying them a lot
of them have to have their feet
amputated or if they don't get to it
quick enough it can spread to other
parts and it's it's really horrific and
this is an organization that goes in and
gets rid of these things and they're
trying to build a clinic specifically
for this because the type of stuff that
these things do and how many of them
there are it's just astounding I've
never even heard of this thing before
but this is going on and if you want to
just donate if you go to their site kill
the digger org you can just go donate
trust me you'll be sending it to a good
cause if you want to look at the videos
or the imagery you can but if you don't
want to I would almost advise not to but
yeah if you don't want to um you can
just go to their website and you can
donate and trust me you would definitely
be sending it to a good good cause these
are people that really don't deserve to
go through this kind of stuff so
definitely go check it out show your
support and donate to something really
great take care